Mike we've been talking about Philip
Rivers career I know you were talking
about that on your show today our poll
question is if you can go back to the 04
draft you got the number one pick and
you need a quarterback i'll give you Eli
bin or Philip who you taking oh well
that's a good that's a better question
the one we had that's pretty good
whoever came up with that one that's
good I'm just buying time because I
really don't know I take Roethlisberger
yeah I would too yeah but is it close
with the number to pick between Manning
and rivers no I say it's close with
number one I mean I'll due respect to
Eli Manning although he brought a couple
of the most memorable moments we've ever
had in a Super Bowl I think for me it's
it's a close Roethlisberger versus
rivers with with Eli at number three but
I gladly take any of the three guys but
what is it about Eli where it feels like
we under eight him during the regular
season and maybe he's overrated during
the postseason I think the problem with
Eli is the thing that allows him to be
so successful in pressure packed moments
keeps him from being as successful as he
needs to be in the regular season he
just doesn't get fired up he doesn't get
in your face he doesn't lead in a way
that we've seen guys like his brother
Peyton do and tom brady and and just
that that very strong drive it may be it
is all internalized but it doesn't come
through so it's harder to get the guys
around him to be as accountable as a
pace Manning would have held his team
teammates to be accountable but then
when you get to the playoffs and it's a
bigger deal guys like peyton manning
seem to appreciate how big of a deal it
is Eli just doesn't seem to care and I
think that's what allows him to have
those great moments he doesn't get
overwhelmed by the pressure and so I
think you take the good in the bad
together it hurts you in the regular
season but it helps you in the
postseason because he's not freaked out
by anything if he didn't have super bowl
rings woody be all of Famer Eli Manning
when he would be on track to be I mean
he's got the tenth most passing yards of
all time I think if you get to 50,000
career passing yards you get in because
Warren moons in with 49 325 and he
doesn't have super bowl rings so he's
working
way toward it quietly piling up the this
the statistics and the performances but
you know those two rings are going to
help him tremendously without them it
would be a much tougher question but is
that magic number fifty thousand passing
yards or three hundred touchdowns well I
I think that that you probably need to
have both 50,000 passing yards is a lot
and and despite the proliferation of
offense the last 40 years Dan there
still aren't many guys who have 50,000
there's only six guys who have fifty
thousand or more passing yards the three
hundred touchdowns are nice and Eli's
one away from from that so he's closer
to that standard then to the 50,000 and
I think he ends up getting both and and
with or without the Rings he probably
gets in it also helps to have the last
name Manning I mean let's be realistic
about playing in New York to and your
two wins in the Super Bowl came against
the Patriots as well yeah Philip Rivers
his fault now Philip Rivers Hall of
Famer I think he will be I think when
he's done he'll have the numbers right
now if he walked off I don't think he'd
get it my very loose litmus test is if
you have fewer career passing yards and
Vinny Testaverde you don't get in he's
got 46 233 once you pass testaverde you
can get in with or without a Super Bowl
ring and I think if you get to 50 you're
in and I think he has a good chance to
get to 50 he's at 43 in change and
depending upon how much longer he wants
to play he should get to 50 so he gets
there right now he's not eventually he
does Aikman 32,000 but he's got those
three Super Bowl rings and I think
that's the key the three Super Bowl
rings and the guy who was the leader of
one of the great teams of all time one
of the the you know last dynasties of
the pre free agency era and right on the
cusp of when free agency started to rip
great teams apart so you know we made
that a no brainer for him because of the
success look at Lynn Swann Lynn Swann is
not in without for super bowl ring she's
not within in without Super Bowl ten
that those rings no matter what the
voters tell you those carry a lot of
weight and when you have three of them
like Aikman it doesn't matter that you
have fewer passing yards than Steve de
Burgh he said Mike Florio
profootballtalk.com the NBC Sports
Network I I had to laugh when I heard
Brett Favre say Tony
romo should basically take one for the
team and volunteer not to want to go
back in and start because don't want to
break up the winning rhythm formula here
with dak Prescott could you imagine
favre being injured and Aaron Rodgers
playing well in favre going you know
what it's probably best for the Packers
if I just sit well I think far would
have played with the broken back that's
the same he was so determined to never
yield his spot anyone and and he's
admitted that when he was a backup be
kind of secretly rooted for the starter
when the starter went down to not be
able to get up that's how badly he
wanted in he wasn't given up that spot
so yeah there's just a little irony in
pharr suggesting to Tony Romo take a
seat as far as the last guy who would
have when healthy voluntarily given up
his job Annie well we would have killed
we would kill Tony Romo if he said you
know what I I'll just sit here and and
let dak Plei we would like where's the
competitor in here I I know it's getting
to the point if dak Prescott wins these
next two games I just can't see the
cowboys going back to Rome oh and I said
from the beginning I thought Jerry Jones
would go back to him with his loyalty
let him play until you know something
happened but Romo has to feel like hey
Dax done a great job but I'm a better
quarterback than dak Prescott and I will
be even better when I get in there I
think the cowboys believe that to dan
and the primary source of relief and
almost euphoria from the Cowboys is they
found the next guy yeah who knows what
that Prescott's ever going to be but now
they can quit worrying about having no
one when Tony Romo retires now the
problem that comes out of that is there
could be an awkward passing the baton at
some point where the baton actually gets
ripped out of Romo's hands this year I
don't think they're gonna play games
with this whole you know is Tony Romo
really air quotes healthy and maybe
we're going to give another week or two
to heal while dad keeps playing and
we'll keep stringing this out until dak
has a regression I think they're gonna
put Romo back when he's ready my
understanding is week 8 or week 9 that's
either against the eagles on sunday
night football or at cleveland but
they're going to go with him when he's
ready the one factor that i thought
would tempt jerry jones he is so
determined to be responsible for the
building of a championship team
Romo's not his guy that's a bill
parcells guy dak Prescott is Jerry Jones
guy but that loyalty to Romo is there he
wants to win a super bowl with Tony Romo
and I think Romo gets back on the field
when he's truly healthy not some phony
high bar where the doctors say he's not
ready when he really is they're gonna
put him out there when he's ready and if
he gets hurt they don't have to worry
anymore because they have a guy who can
come in and help them win games I'll
leave you with this one of Colin
Kaepernick plays well well look at Brock
Osweiler last year dance seven games
played well enough 18 million a year on
the open market there will be a team
next year if Kaepernick plays well over
the next 11 games that is ready to pay
him a significant amount of money
because there aren't enough quarterbacks
to go around and if he looks like he did
in 2012 and 2013 he's going to make a
lot of money on the open market which is
why I think he gave up that 14.5 million
dollar injury guarantee for next year
and now quarterbacks are confident to
the point of delusional he could be
delusional but if he does look good he
will make more than 14 and a half
million next year from someone is is his
career done in San Francisco after this
year now if he plays really well and
having success as a team and having
success as an individual goes a long way
towards strengthening relationships
maybe you have to redo the deal again
well yeah that's true that they would
and and and they'd be happy to if Chip
Kelly decides this is my guy and this is
the guy I want he's always very fickle
about his quarterbacks though he always
thinks there's someone else he can find
to come in and do the job but if he
plays incredibly well and they turn this
thing around a lot of ifs there but but
if that happens it's a different vibe
all together right now the vibe is it's
time for him to move on 11 games later
if somehow they scratch and claw wild
card berth out of this and he plays
really well may they may have to revisit
it and he may have to revisit whether he
wants to stay there we go somewhere else
thank you Michael C on Sunday alright
see that Mike Florio pro football time
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience